david rudy giuliani is finally
formally under investigation do you
think he will end up serving prison time
you know ev every time i answer one of
these questions with
no he's not going to go to prison i get
emails from people saying
david you fool
you are making it less likely that these
people will go to prison
by saying it's unlikely they're going to
go to prison no i'm not
my show's audience this show is just not
nearly big enough for me to say that and
for it to have any kind of effect
rudy giuliani is not going to go to
prison rudy giuliani
is 76 years old and i'm not saying he
shouldn't be investigated or prosecuted
as a result of that
we now know there's an investigation
into rudy going on
his home and office were raided last
week as we reported
um he may have broken lobbying law
he may have broken all sorts of laws we
don't know what's going on with rudy
giuliani
it's possible that the investigation
will lead to charges for rudy giuliani
if there are charges against rudy
giuliani the most
common scenario that i would expect
because of rudy giuliani's place in
society
and his access and his privilege would
be that
there is some kind of a plea agreement
or cooperation agreement
michael cohen trump's former lawyer
believes that rudy would
flip and spill the beans on trump
because rudy doesn't want to get in
trouble himself
so i think that there would be some kind
of plea deal if there's no plea deal
and it actually and if if there is a
plea deal anything
rudy pleads to would have no jail time
there's no doubt about it let's say
there's no
plea deal and this thing actually goes
to trial
is it going to be a guilty verdict i
don't know
if there is a guilty verdict we're like
four or five maybes
in right now if there is a guilty
verdict
there may be no jail time anyway
associated with that as per the judge
and even if by this time when rudy will
be
77 or 78 or 79 who knows how long this
thing could go on
even if there is jail time i would fully
expect
that rudy's lawyer whoever it is at the
time who knows how many lawyers rudy
will have been through at that point in
time
i would expect rudy's lawyer would
successfully argue that the sentence be
suspended or that it be home confinement
or whatever based on rudy's age and
possible health
situation so when you put all of that
together
i think the odds of rudy ever seeing any
prison time
are i mean i think one in a thousand is
it's when these when the percentages are
so small it's hard to make them really
tangible is it one in a thousand that
rudy sees jail time i know it's not one
in a hundred
is it one in two thousand but if i were
a betting man
on even odds i'm saying no you would
have to give me some crazy odds for me
to bet that rudy sees the inside of a
jail cell other than
for some reason unrelated to him being
being prosecuted and charged
if you disagree with me let me know
i'm open to having my mind changed but i
don't see it we have a fantastic
bonus show today what yes
there's an extra show every day for our
members
sign up at joinpakman.com we will see
you then